monsieur le ministre comment en
sommes-nous arrivés là à devoir
consommer des grillons de la même
famille que les sauterelles ou les
criquets alors que la France est le pays
de la gastronomie et des terroirs
comment pouvez-vous laisser faire cela
alors que vous n'avez de cesse de nous
parler d'une alimentation saine et
durable d'agroécologie et de circuits
courts scène et durable cette farine ne
l'est pas même la Commission ne garantit
pas l'absence de problèmes sanitaires
contrairement à ce que vous venez de
dire où est l'agroécologie avec
l'élevage hors sol de millions de
grillons dans des bâtiments industriels
et que dire des circuits courts alors
que cette poudre de Grillon est importée
du Vietnam cette Commission européenne
qui cède au lobby antiviande et qui sape
notre agriculture et notre culture
gastronomique je n'en veux plus
soutenant plutôt la farine de blé
française plutôt que la farine de
soutenant le sucre français plutôt que
les insectes d'Asie nous ne pouvons pas
accepter de faire manger à leur insu des
insectes aux Français ceux qui
souhaitent manger des grillons monsieur
le ministre je les invite à venir les
manger directement dans mes prés ils
seront nature entier nombre broyés et
non transformés et pour tous les autres
je leur conseille de constituer que de
continuer à manger une bonne côte de
bœuf
[Applaudissements]